hey guys it's just stayed and I wanted
to do an updated island tour my island
is officially five stars and I have over
600 hours in this game I know oh my
goodness I'm not proud but I'm also
proud because I've done a lot of my
Island I'm also accidentally in the
southern hemisphere for those of you who
are wondering why it looks like an icy
tundra it's also dark I planned on
recording this earlier so that you guys
could have a nice sunny day maybe I'll
do a quick run-through tomorrow when the
Sun is up so you guys can see what it
looks like in the daytime but this is my
island and it is currently winter on the
southern hemisphere so let's first start
our tour from the airport if you do
arrive to my island you will be greeted
here and when you exit the wonderful
airport you'll be greeted here with the
entryway that is made of ice at first
I'm gonna show you guys my map so you
guys can see what we're working with
this is my house this is my second house
I made it for my dog so that I could use
it for storage these are my villagers
Francine meringue Rolfe Bella lucky
Raymond we did a 10 hour stream to get
Raymond that's a whole nother story
we have Knox kid it's actually his
birthday today Aurora and Adi and again
Maddy
so here's my map here's how everything
is laid out we will slowly but surely
get to everything so what I really
wanted for this island was I wanted to
be able to go directly from the airport
all the way to my house and that is what
we've achieved with this current layout
so I can go all the way up here to my
house here's mine and here is Maddy's
house so we have a couple of different
options here so we have two areas that
are housing developments which is this
one and then we have like you saw on my
map that is on the other side save some
houses over here this is Ravens house
and there's multiple ways to get to each
one of you
little areas so this will take you back
down here but we're gonna go back to the
airport so that I can show you how you
get around the island so back to the
airport it'll take us all the way down
here and it has gone away go back down
to the airport and we will go like we've
just entered and we're gonna go here to
the left so this is my Plaza area which
is pretty cool because I have a little
arcade here behind the arcade is where
we have our little I never know exactly
what to call this what do they call this
the residence center I call it the
courthouse just because that just seems
like what it should be called if we're
going to the courthouse I need to check
in here I actually didn't do this
yesterday so from the courthouse we'll
go over here this is our museum we've
got a nice little t-rex here and Museum
here got some cherry trees but the snow
just looks so beautiful and with the
moonlight reflecting off of it
pretty romantic I must say that's amber
here now this will take us back here to
the beach I was going to make this into
a little stage area but I think I'm
gonna just kind of make it into a little
picnic area nothing too crazy happening
on the beach but the boardwalk will kind
of lead us back here and then this
boardwalk area will take us to this nice
little bar area when I see a butterfly I
just have to catch it I just can't help
it this will take us over to our shop
areas we've got nook's cranny and we've
got our able sisters here this is a
little area that I've just been using to
kind of hoard my snowmen I love their
dialog so much I also got the little
briefcase full of money full of what
money this is also another little area
that will take you down to the beach and
I have put a lot of effort into making
sure that my entire island you can get
to places very quickly you'll notice
also that there's no paths because these
are custom paths right here this will
lead us all the way to the housing area
development so my house and Maddie's
house is here
but this area will take you back here
and this will take you into my little
flower area so this is all black and
gold roses that have been bred before
when I was obsessed with breeding
flowers they were all here and I took
better care of them but now not so much
this is sort of a progress of making a
blue rose but I kind of gave up so this
will all be saved later for farming so
while we're up here in the flower area
this is where red sometimes resides like
what once every five months at this
point come on red
we need you this will take us down to
the beach and the beach will wrap around
here to our second area of villagers
this is Knox he's a murderer so we've
given him a lot of murderous items we've
got a casket we've got this nice barrel
for him to boil bodies I I don't know
I'm not sure I didn't make it up he has
caskets in his house oh my gosh look at
the Aurora it's beautiful and the moon
over there is just looking fantastic and
there's also a little water over here
give me that I'll take you to okay
you're gone what a beautiful evening I'm
so glad that we could be here to
celebrate this wonderful day together so
this little area is another little
village spot and that brings us back
here where we walked all the way up to
the flowers so we're go back down here
because there is a little section that I
did not show you so I've been live
streaming on Twitch recently and Mike
Shinoda has also been live streaming and
he's usually streaming right after I'm
done streaming so we have been reading
his channel and I jokingly said that we
should try to get Mike Shinoda to come
to my island so this is what we've been
working on for Mike we have been trying
to make him a nice little area so maybe
he would want to come perform a cake a
slider song but it is coming together
very very nicely like I'm obsessed with
how great this looks this is really the
reason why I wanted to show you guys
this at night because the stage
looks even better it looks cool during
the day but like I mean this would be
Evora I mean that's just the Northern
Lights even though I'm in the southern
hemisphere geography it's something it's
something that I should have paid
attention to when I started this game
and not chosen the southern hemisphere
either way it's cool and I just love the
winter it's so fun I just wish that I
did have summer so that I could have
summer during my summer but it's okay
I've still been enjoying it so either
way I'm looking forward to hopefully one
day getting to show this to Mike Shinoda
I think you will enjoy it or not
either way we made it and we made it
live on stream so a lot of you guys have
helped make that like I was saying
before this takes you all the way up to
the flower area but this is where my
campsite is got under snowman there so
here's the campsite we've got all of
these fall leaves because I have also
had fall already and this will take you
over here so this takes you sort of back
to the beginning so everything is very
very well connected so that's from the
airport
it takes you up here so you have the
option of going this way to the campsite
and going to the villager area which is
over here or you can take a little look
at the things that I kind of have here
we've got this cute little coffee shop
area I should probably put maybe a
coffee or something right there but it's
nice and cozy because we have a little
fireplace and we've got some a fire here
so you can stay warm in the winter chill
Oddie's not even she doesn't even care
she's like I'm sitting in the snow with
my donut by the fire hi I forgot I don't
she asks I don't I yep yep I have
nothing to say I'm speechless
hi I lost my voice I was trying to be
happy male singer instead of a pop star
I'm so
well how funny she's incredible I love
her as a character this is my little
space section to go have a couple that
looks I need to take a picture that's
amazing how amazing does that look I
can't even believe it so the space area
got a little cafe I mean this is so
pretty you guys look at this I can't
even get over it ah I've also got a
little snowman hat on like I am fully
embracing everything right now okay
we're gonna go back up here and then
we're gonna take you over here which
will take you directly to the beach area
which will then in turn take you up here
which you I showed you guys before
that'll take up two more other villages
and this is a little cafe by the beach
you guys can lounge here this is so
beautiful I just can't get over it you
can make yourself a little coffee have
it a little tarot cards read whatever
you want it's all here we have it all
here my island name is also called
Promax
my island flag is computer iphone Promax
camera I know this is a little secret
way to get to Bella's house she likes
heavy metal so if it's some stuff there
she likes skulls
she's super cool let's see I know there
was something else that I want to show
you if we go all the way over here
passed by the other villagers we've got
a little water fountain here with some
money trees I also want to note that
I've not time traveled like this is all
just Justine spending way too much time
playing this game these are all of the
flowers that I've bred I put them here
originally because this was all sort of
under construction I just wanted to have
a place to put the flowers so that I
could find somewhere to put them later
and I still haven't found anywhere to
put them so that's currently where they
are this Beach nothing crazy is
happening we've got a little musical
area here if you feel like playing
ukulele we've got all the car beds I
think I'm a good missing one but either
way they're here and did you know you
can do this well now you do my little
pier is over here as well nothing too
crazy you know it's just you know a few
hours of time that I've spent playing
I'm very much so looking forward to the
summer update which is going very
shortly we'll be able to swim and dive
in the ocean I can't freakin wait I'd
also like to show you guys my house I
mean we might as well just go out as
well just go for it I'll show you the
house I'll show you Maddy's house
incredible I don't think it's changed it
that much since you guys maybe have seen
my last video I'm not really sure but
here it is we've got a nice little TV
there got some stuff you know it's it's
a nice blue and pink theme I really like
that pink carpet this is my pink room
this is one of the rooms I think that
really helped me get a gold trophy for
my room now all of these posters some of
my friends have given me during my live
streams up to it oh man we've had some
really good times but this is fun
because when you're looking to try to up
your happy home academy score you do
want to have all of the matching stuff
so I have a lot of the cute matching and
everything is pink
and it looks looks really guys like I'm
a huge fan I love this room so much it's
probably one of my favorite rooms now
we're gonna move on to this other room
this is gonna be the gym I just made
this very early on in quarantine when
all the gyms closed down and I was like
man would it be great to have this gym
look at this we have the cloud flooring
so it kind of gives it that steamy
little look we've got a nice shower this
is probably been running for over a
month I probably should turn that off so
that's that's our little bathroom you
got all of the weight equipment here and
I have some of the awards from me the
the museum hunt and from the happy home
Academy originally all hung up just you
know to make it look like sporty now I
take you guys into a new room since this
is the winter season I decided to make a
room dedicated all to the frozen items
and I think that I have all of the
frozen DIYs we made this on my live
stream this morning actually I thought
we'd have a TV some popsicles
I used the bar as a place to put the
computer I don't really know if that was
the best idea but I I did it anyway I
have a nice little siesta I put a fire
just thought you might be cold it's icy
I'm gonna take you guys upstairs which
is my shooting room so this is my studio
I was gonna shoot an unboxing but I
still never did it yet I think I
eventually will do it I mean at this
point the games been out for a while
this used to look a lot cooler I used to
have all of the servers in the back here
but I had to use them all for being Mike
Shinoda set and I just ordered another
light to go over here I feel like I need
to order another TV I might order
another television and put it next to
the black one and swap the black one out
and put the black one downstairs and
then the red one I might put somewhere
else as well but these are my trophies
from the happy home Academy and also the
bug off that we had I didn't have the
bug off on my Ireland because I'm on the
southern hemisphere but I had to go to
Jenna's island so he streamed I think
for like four and a half hours maybe
longer it was a long time but we got all
the trophies the downstairs is kind of
like my kitchen lounge area I knew that
I wanted to make a really cool kitchen
area with all the iron wood
DIY is after I got them all and then
finally I did and that's sort of what
this room is all about it's a nice look
it also looks really cute without the
lights on - it's by B it's a vibe if you
will I love those hanging lights you can
also customize those I customized them
to be white let's turn the lights back
on got the van Gogh over there actually
got two of those I was still able to
give one to the museum that's this area
now I think that's all my rooms that was
all of my rooms now I'll show you
Maddie's house his is sort of I mean
we'll show it to you it's very basic I
think I only have one room finished in
his house I wanted to do a theme of all
of me oh my god
oh my god tarantula okay are you kidding
me is this happening right now I can't
believe it I have not seen the tarantula
in a very long time this is a gift we're
being given a gift right now guys I
can't believe I just got this situation
just got hairy I can't believe it less
scared me that action oh my Nets going
do you think it's because he knew that I
had my bug bag that I was on the hunt
for him possibly I love this dog house -
check this out it's so cute you're gonna
go to Maddie's house so originally on
stream I wanted to turn this into an
Apple store but it well mmm yeah this
happened we never finished it it's kind
of like a Radio Shack at this point
like no offense Radio Shack but it's
definitely not an Apple store this is
the only room I do have done I wanted to
make like a little I guess an antique
room because I kept buying antique
furniture and I don't really like the
antique furniture why won't my light
turn on if I mess something up - I don't
have it else cuz not my house I can't
turn the light on this is not my house
so this is his antique room it was his
birthday on the 17th of June so he's got
all of his little birthday things his
little birthday cake and a little
cupcake that he got it as party that's
actually six cupcakes to stack it also
looks nice with the lights on
but I can't turn them on because it's
not my house I mean it is my house
no but it's not my house so that's it
that's pretty much my whole tour of my
island and my houses he has nothing
upstairs it's a completely empty room
the other two rooms are also completely
empty but I basically just use his
character as a storage character so
that's it you know this area also comes
down here got some money trees up there
probably get that can't believe we just
caught a tarantula Oh a fossil really
even what do I need that for it I don't
because I have completed my fossil in
the drug what do you think this is an
orange rug it's really boring so that my
friends is my island this is what I've
been working on over the past several
months during quarantine I've also been
having so much fun doing live streams
I've been doing them not every morning
but a lot of mornings just hanging out
with you guys over on Twitch if you want
to check it out I'll probably do a live
stream here as well I can probably dual
stream I'll try to figure it out and see
if I can watch both chats at the same
time while we play we've been having a
lot of fun and I hope to see you guys
over there if you guys are new here I do
a lot of videos about tech not
necessarily all about Animal Crossing
but I love video games
I love tech and I just love making
videos really so welcome if you're new
hello welcome back if you're not and I
will see you guys in my next video and
if you guys love Animal Crossing look
forward to that
some are update I hope I'll even give
the summer update because it's not
summer I guess we'll find out alright
I'll see you guys okay I'm done for real
we're done now I'll see you later bye
[Music]